welcome back to the david pakman show i
am fair and cousins from ring of fire
sitting in for david pakman today and
if you happen to enjoy me here you can
catch me on the ring of fire youtube
channel
youtube.com the ring of fire you can
also find me on my youtube channel
youtube.com fahren balanced
of course i'm all over all social media
outlets facebook twitter instagram at
farren balanced now let's talk about
covet for a minute right
obviously biggest story happening in the
country right now
especially as we have children heading
back to school within the next few weeks
florida where i am right now 20 percent
of nationwide coveted cases coming from
this state
our kids go back to school today
and we still don't have statewide mass
mandates because our governor
ron desantis actually signed a ban
on masked mandates it was an executive
order to be uh perfectly honest
and the republican-controlled
legislature by the way
a long time ago during the pandemic
actually gave him the authority
to do that now as i mentioned on this
program
on friday some counties have defied
santis order desantis's order and so
over the weekend though you had
republican senator bill cassidy from the
state of louisiana actually come out
on cnn state of the union and take a
couple shots
at ron desantis for banning mask
mandates for children in school
here's what cassidy said i'm a
conservative
i think you govern best when you govern
closest to the people being governed
and if a local community is having a
their icu is full and
the people at the local schools see that
they've got to make sure they stay open
because otherwise children miss out on
for another year of school
and they put in policy then the local
officials should be listened
to now
he kind of didn't say that as clearly as
possible but he was asked about the mass
mandates
because we have one here in florida they
got one in texas two of the worst states
in the country with kovid
and that was his response like you gotta
let the local officials make those
decisions
not every county here in the state of
florida is as bad as the one next to it
now it's bad all over the state don't
get me wrong
but this should be this the decision
excuse me
up to the local officials here but
desantis took away
cities and counties right to make that
decision for themselves and that is what
cassidy is actually taking a swipe at
here
we've seen it happen in arkansas we're
seeing it happen in
texas where the actual
authority is being stripped from local
communities
and instead given to one person at the
top of that food chain
florida it's desantis arkansas who now
says he regrets it is hutchinson
texas it's abbot meanwhile louisiana
who is also seeing a massive spike in
covet they're going back to mass
mandates
okay it's a red state but
they have enough good sense to say
listen
things are bad and so we have to go back
to this if people
aren't going to voluntarily protect
themselves we're going to have to put
the law
in place the rule in place that says you
have to protect yourself because it's
not just you
it's literally everybody else around you
and that's when it changes from being
about
personal choice as too many republicans
want to say
to a public policy health issue and that
is
something that can be governed that is
something that can be legislated
if it is a public health concern what
you and your individual choices
are then yeah that can be regulated
people love to use the example of drunk
driving
and that really is a great example if
you want to sit on your couch
and drink a handle of vodka and then
just pass out for the night
that's your personal choice okay and as
long as you're of age nobody can stop
you from doing that
however if you want to drink that same
amount of alcohol then get behind the
wheel of a vehicle
then yeah suddenly that's a public
health concern
and we do have laws against that because
at that point you put
other people in danger it's the same
with not wearing masks
maybe not to such an extreme extent
but we do have a virus that is still
mutating
that is still spreading that is highly
transmission transmissible
the delta variant is much more likely
to make children sick than you know
covet original
and this is what we're dealing with
right now so
while i may not agree with him on quite
possibly anything else i do applaud
senator cassidy for taking the time and
responding to the question correctly
he could have been a little more overt
about it but i'm not going to damn for
that
this should be a decision that's up to
each individual school board
after hearing from parents after
listening to medical professionals
because we've seen far too many videos
by the way of angry deranged anti-vaxxer
parents
saying we don't need vaccines we don't
need masks you can probably ignore those
people
maybe have the school board just meet
with doctors
or maybe have them go visit the
hospitals
in states like florida and texas that
are currently filling up and then
they should be the ones to make the
decision on whether mask mandates go
into place
if you've been watching the show you've
probably heard me talk about how much i
love
my helix mattress well i was really
excited to hear that helix has launched
a new company called
all form which makes premium
customizable sofas and chairs
with the same level of quality and
comfort
that i expect from these guys and all
form is one of our sponsors today
they're giving you twenty percent off at
allforum.com
pacman they actually sent me a couch
which i put
in my living room at home it's now my
favorite piece of furniture
in the house it took me just minutes to
set it up
it's solidly built it's huge it's roomy
it has a modern minimalist design which
i love but it's also
very comfortable fabric is soft clearly
very high quality it has become the
focal point of my living room their
prices are very reasonable and when you
get a new sofa or
chair you get 100 days to decide
if you want to keep it and the best part
is everything comes
with a lifetime warranty stop buying
poorly made furniture go to customize
your own all form sofa or chair right
now
and get twenty percent off your entire
order when you get there
by going to all form dot com slash
pacman
i've also put the link right underneath
this video